alright well this year the economic loss
of the global economy will be around the
150 one hundred percent very low
especially at the growth rate of the
major industrial economy to be negative
equitably also in the case of Japan we
expect minus 1 by 2 percent growth
though the government is expecting flat
we also do custom to close on anyway
this year we have very serious situation
but beyond that we'll be able to see
some sign of recovery so therefore the
development especially macroeconomic
management very very important this year
at the same time we expect a lot through
the good governance and the taconic
policy by october government in the
United States to sue I'm a very good
impact on the global economy in the
total thank you